hey i'm katie and welcome back to
tasty's hack or hassle
on this show tasty producers try to make
a recipe testing a bunch of hacks in a
row that have been collected by our
friend amy
now i am not an expert i am not an
italian grandma so please don't come for
me
but i do love to make pasta in my spare
time so today we're just going to test
out these hacks and see which ones are
helpful and just like which ones are a
total hassle
[Music]
so today i'm going to be making a
classic spaghetti and meatballs much
like the one we have
here it's got spaghetti it has a rich
tomato sauce
and on top we've got some cute little
meatballs and we're gonna be making
fresh pasta by hand all right so let's
get into this
the first thing we're gonna do is add
some salt to flour
and i'm doing this in the bowl because
our first hack
is to make a well in a bowl so normally
you would turn this out onto your
surface and then you would make a well
which is going to take your wet
ingredients but we're doing it in a bowl
and this is actually a hack that i've
done before because often
my wells collapse and it becomes really
messy
this hack we're just gonna make it in
the bowl and this way it can't collapse
outside of itself
and six egg yolks and then we're gonna
add a tablespoon of olive oil
so first i'm just gonna combine all the
egg yolks and get those all broken up
and this makes for like a smoother less
clumpy dough
you've gotten this pretty well
incorporated it's starting to get real
chunky boy now so i'm gonna put this out
onto the counter now there's no pretty
way to do this
oh you know what is a pretty way to do
this this is not a hack but you can use
a bench scraper sometimes not all of the
flour
is gonna incorporate into your eggs and
your oil
so what's not coming together like that
didn't naturally cling to this we're
just gonna get rid of it rejection so
the next hack
is a kneading hack so the traditional
kneading is you go away from yourself
and you bring it back but we're gonna do
the heart method is the hack and this is
actually from a tasty 101 so you make a
heart shape you go like this
and then you go like this i think this
hack it just depends on like
what you would like to do i like that
it's a heart like it's romantic
i would say that i prefer the
traditional method which is
this way so basically i'm gonna just
keep kneading this until the gluten is
really developed and when you press your
finger into the dough it springs back
so we're just gonna wrap this in plastic
we'll just let this sit out at room
temperature
for about 30 minutes to an hour
pasta recipes can vary some are very dry
some are really sticky so i flour my
surface i'm gonna cut him into
eights so that we don't have too long of
sheets and then the dough that you're
not working with just make sure you keep
that covered because
you don't want your pasta dough to dry
out so we just want to make sure we get
this nice and thin because if you send
it through the pasta roller when it's
too thick
it'll break so now we've got a pasta
roller i have a cool electric one and
we're just having this on setting the
first setting which is one
and you don't want to pull your pasta
like it just let it come out on its own
we're gonna fold it into a square like
this
and we'll just feed it through again and
this is gonna help get a better
shape so now we're gonna go up to two
so as you go higher it gets thinner and
now we'll go to three
or four and we're gonna go to five
is the thinnest that will roll it okay
and we've got our sheet you want it so
that you can see your fingers through it
it's nice and translucent
and i'm just gonna repeat this with our
remaining dough and then we'll move on
to cutting this into spaghetti
now it's time to cut it i have added a
spaghetti cutter
attachment extruder what do you call it
i don't know it cut spaghetti we're
gonna turn on our machine
this is my favorite part some guys might
fall down that are not the same length
you don't have to be a hero trying to
catch them
i don't know why it makes me so happy
now here's our next hack we could put
this on a drying rack but
since we're gonna eat our pasta
relatively quickly we don't really need
to do that so the hack
is you dust up some flour on these guys
we're gonna do this before we set it
down because we don't want them to stick
together
and you can set them down here and then
just nest them
and i actually like to add a little bit
more flour in here and then
you twirl cute they're like little
eggness i highly recommend this hack
because you don't really need to buy the
drying rack unless you're going to be
drying your pasta overnight but if
you're gonna eat it that night
you really don't need that extra gadget
we're gonna set these guys aside and let
them sit for 30 minutes while we work on
the sauce i feel like this is a metaphor
for my life like you know when i start
off on something it's not so great but
it can get better
i can get better
so now we're moving on to the sauce i'm
actually gonna be using jar sauce
and you're gonna find out why but the
first thing we need to do is prep some
garlic for this
sauce and we have like way too many
garlic hacks
to try but i also love garlic so i'm
excited
basically you break up your garlic
if you can see they all still have the
little peels on them so the first one
we're gonna try
is you take your garlic cloves and
you shake them between two metal bowls
so let's see
very musical let's see was that enough
some of it's still on but for the most
part these guys are
pretty good that's a pretty good hack
there's another version of this hack
where it's in a tupperware container so
let's see if that actually works faster
one two three
oh okay we have one that's done
the other four are not as good so this
one maybe it's because this top is
rubber the next one
we saw on tick tock you cut off the base
well in the video it doesn't come apart
like this all right we're gonna try that
again i am now equipped with a serrated
knife hopefully these teeth
are gonna help us out
okay i'm gonna just say no it's a hassle
the whole bottom is supposed to cut off
and then you're supposed to just
press down and then magically
all of the peel comes off but it's very
much
has all its clothes on so to protect my
hands for this one
we don't know if it works obviously that
last one didn't i'm gonna use gloves
and a paring knife and the idea is that
you just stick this knife
in and then you keep going in a circle
this one's kind of dangerous so
just cue disclaimer right here here we
go
so they're going in at an angle and
they're kind of like
pulling it towards them and then it
magically comes out
that did not happen for me okay as
things are coming out it's easier to do
but what i am still noticing is that
it's not actually like how you shake it
in the bowl and then you have all of the
the peel gone that's still there
like in the video this person is rapidly
doing it it looks effortless
and they're very good at it maybe i'm
just not good but there were a lot of
comments that said this didn't work
i kind of i'm on the side with the
comments so we're gonna say
hassle so i'm just gonna mince up this
garlic and we'll move on to the next
hack
so now we're gonna be making our sauce
which is our next hack we're gonna
upgrade this jarred sauce so the first
thing we'll do
is heat up some olive oil and then we
will saute
our four cloves of garlic you just wanna
cook it so it gets a little tender
and you can start to smell and it's
fragrant i would wear garlic as a
perfume
is that weird probably we're going to
now add balsamic vinegar
so this is going to deglaze the pan but
it's also going to add like a brightness
more acidity
and some sweetness so now we will add
our jarred pasta this is about 20 ounces
a half a cup of heavy cream which i like
this idea
it's just gonna add some richness to our
sauce i think it's pretty
common that people will do this with a
jar of sauce so far i really like this
hack i feel like it's a good time saving
hack
so the next thing we have to do is bring
this up to a simmer so while this is
simmering we're gonna move on to making
meatballs
okay so first what we're gonna do is add
some beef
and some pork it's not glamorous folks
and then a little tip for my friend matt
add some ricotta this just adds a lot of
moisture
and then we'll add some milk get your
bread crumbs in there
parmesan of course and the eggs are just
gonna help bind all of this together and
then we're just gonna get in there with
our hands
and squish it all together so our next
hack
is gonna involve this an egg carton
i'm as afraid as you are and it's gonna
go in the oven so
we're all afraid you cannot forget
seasoning so let me just add that in
real fast we're going to add some salt
here
and some pepper so this hack is an alton
brown hack when you
cook these in the oven a lot of fat
drains off them and grease and it like
pools at the bottom and so the carton is
supposed to absorb all of that grease
and make you know make less greasy
meatballs so i'm just going to use this
ice cream scoop here this just make sure
all your meatballs are around the same
size
we just set it in and that's what we're
doing i don't know if this hack is a
hassle or a good hit but we'll know as
soon as it cooks
let's go bake these at 4 25 for 20
minutes and see if this hack
works
[Music]
so you guys may notice we're outside and
that's for safety reasons just in case
this carton catches fire for any reason
in this oven outside look how still
it's just like by itself all right so
our oven is preheated to 425
i'm gonna put our bad boys in there
we're gonna wait 20 minutes
all right everybody i have let these
cool a little bit so that i can handle
them
we're gonna try to take these out i'm a
little nervous that they're gonna stick
to the cardboard my nervousness was
right
they are sticking okay well wow okay so
the tops got very
crispy but the bottoms are a little
soggy i don't know if this really works
very well because even if i take them
out while they're piping hot this base
is still not
crispy it's kind of soggy and you really
want an all-around crisp on your
meatballs hassle
okay so we're near the end and i've got
some boiling water here so one of the
hacks is to salt your water
after it's been boiling it takes longer
if the salt is in there
for it to boil and also i guess in
stainless steel pans it can
hit on the bottom of it and cause like a
discoloration the next hack is to avoid
iodized salt
a lot of table salt is iodized salt but
we're using kosher
iodized salt has a more metallic taste
than kosher salt so
that's why just avoid it so that your
pasta doesn't get like a metallicy taste
so then the next one is to salt this
until it's like seawater so we'll see if
this makes our pasta a lot more
flavorful at the end and i think it's a
good technique okay our sauce is
simmering our water is boiling
let's cook our pasta fresh pasta cooks
really quickly in about like two to
three minutes depending on the thickness
of it
the next hack is says to stir the pasta
for
two minutes to keep it from sticking
together fresh pasta is really delicate
so
stirring this for two minutes a seems
like a waste of time but b
like also you could like damage your
pasta the next hack to test if our pasta
is done i feel like i've only seen this
in movies but we're gonna try it
is to throw a piece of the pasta at the
wall
and then if it sticks then it's done
ah stop okay i think someone just wanted
to throw pasta at a wall
okay so this is done according to that
it's been about a minute and a half
and i don't want to overdo it so the
next hack is to strain this
using the colander like this i don't
know if this is easier
okay here we go oh steam
pasta facial do not rent your pasta i
don't think this is a hack this is just
life advice don't rinse your pasta i
actually like that hack
that wasn't actually that bad most
people would tell you not to do this
hack
but annie is forcing me to do it to keep
your pasta from sticking to itself
you're gonna add olive oil so why this
hack exists i guess is to keep the pasta
from sticking to itself
but what actually happens is it stops
the sauce from adhering to the pasta
we'll see how much it affects the taste
so this next hack is
again i think more of a technique it's
put your pasta in the sauce instead of
your sauce
in the pasta and this way the pasta
actually like
cooks a little bit more with the sauce
and really melds together on the heat
you'll cook it till it's al dente even
just a little bit before it's al dente
so that it can cook another minute in
this sauce we made it to the end we did
all the hacks
now we get to eat
all right this is my pasta next to our
previous
example and honestly they look pretty
close
but now i've got to taste this to see if
it's any good
so we salted that water to be as salty
as the ocean and
i'm not getting like a hit of salt pasta
is really flavorful the noodles taste
really yummy i am however getting that
like jar of sauce even though we added
the cream
it definitely made that sauce taste
richer so adding the oil
it definitely seems like a little bit
more oily which is also maybe what i'm
getting in the sauce itself is having
that olive oil then with the pasta sauce
i don't think you need to do it
especially if you're
putting your pasta right into the sauce
after you drain it you don't need to add
olive oil a lot of the hacks were fun or
more techniques but they were good the
meatballs though are the most
disappointing to me
they just don't look good they don't
look appetizing they're not crispy all
around so my favorite hacks from today
were
one doing the well in the bowl that was
great just
had no accidents which i usually do two
upgrading the jar of sauce
i actually think it's a really good hack
just to save time adding that cream it
just made that sauce
really rich and yummy and three i
actually really liked putting the
colander
over the pot and straining it that way
it was really quick and easy and
i actually think it worked really well
thank you guys for watching i'm gonna go
eat the rest of this pasta and i'll see
you later
[Music]